for almost as long as movie theaters
have been around they have been
threatened first it was TV then the VCR
then the internet but guess what each
time movie theaters strike back with
things like IMAX 3d and and now this big
old seats look up at these seats on AMC
right now is renovating its theatres and
then the process is ripping out the
older smaller seats reducing capacity by
64% but in the feeders that they've
already renovated attendance is up 84%
and that has a lot to do with these bad
boys right here
you got yourself power recline
my drink here and you got your armrest
here if you're here with a friend you
know you're hanging out the cozy nice so
why are they MC doing all of this well
to make more money and it's working if
you go back to 1995 the movie theater
industry had total revenues of 5.3
billion dollars but today
aided by comfier seats and better snack
bars with fancy-schmancy coca-cola
freestyle machines those numbers have
doubled there is an irony to what AMC is
doing here
right I mean in order to compete with
your home setup maybe now you've got a
60 inch LED TV and 8.1 surround sound in
order to get you out of your house and
into a theater AMC has to make its
theaters more like your home